introduce you to Joyce Maynard Joyce and
I go way back we figure that it's about
22 years because um Joyce's daughter
Audrey was an infant when Joyce
interviewed me for the New York Times
Magazine
of course I already knew who she was I'd
read her first memoir looking back Joyce
was the enfant Arab of American
journalism I lived in New Mexico far
from any hip literary crowd far from any
literary crowd um I barely knew any
other writers she was 23 I was 40 I was
dreading the interview and yet something
wonderful happened that day long before
I ever read a word of what Joyce wrote
about me we bonded we were soul sisters
mothers writers um struggling young
women and ever since we've been good
friends I have read everything that
Joyce has written over the years from
her charming witty often poignant
newspaper columns to her smart funny
often emotional novels for years we've
corresponded sometimes sharing our most
intimate feelings and yet
Joyce never once mentioned having known
Salinger I heard it from a literary
agent because Salinger and I shared the
same literary agency I didn't believe
him I called Joyce and asked if it was
true she said I never talked about that
and she never did not to me today
however she is here to share with you
her point of view my friend Joyce Manor
I guess I need that mic thank you so
much Judy it's M I I don't think we've
ever shared a stage together it's a real
treat I was thinking so many aspects of
Judy's introduction I felt a need to
respond to starting with that all font
area phrase which over the 20-some years
that passed evolved into what I was
called most recently last last year when
this book was published aging nymphet
that's not the worst of it I also want
to correct you Judy in one in when
you've corrected youth you pronounce my
name correctly but thank God you have
not read everything I've written it
would be a very poor idea to do that
I've I'm one of that tiny little group
that has completely has never had a job
in her life actually I had one job when
I was 22 years old and never again and
it doesn't mean that I've been living
off of a trust fund it means that I've
been working as a freelance writer
supporting my family as a writer for
almost 30 years now which means that you
write an awful lot of very unmemorable
prose and I'm glad that you Judy have
forgotten it or haven't run into it my
assessment of various brands of sports
bras in in fitness magazine you probably
never got around you and I'm not ashamed
to say that at a literary festival
because it is possible to be both a a
working writer and a person who
approaches writing as a job and also
somebody who aspires to art and and
sometimes accomplishes it and and when
she doesn't pays the bills and I make no
apology about having been the first and
I hope on occasion the second you know I
had planned to spend about the first 45
minutes of our but I consider our
precious time together today telling my
story and then leaving about 15 minutes
for questions after
yesterday's presentations and hearing
the the moving a glorious work of the
writers that that have been speaking to
us all I decided not to do that
I actually I was sitting in the audience
last night listening to an Chi Minh and
feeling my god what do I have to say and
my guess is that probably there may have
been because I'm sure there are people
in this group who are working on memoir
or some form of memoir themselves and
and were there some of you who were
feeling that oh goodness I wasn't I
didn't escape from China and have 50
leeches in my foot and and and have my
friend commit suicide what do I possibly
have to say and so I want to among other
things address and reassure you on that
point
that without knowing your stories I can
say with absolute certainty you do have
something to say when I was little and I
used to have hard times or what I
thought were hard times and I'd be
crying I'd go to my mother
she would say to me out of the best
intentions in the world I'm sure she'd
say well at least you aren't in a
concentration camp i this didn't really
cheer me up and I guess it's sort of you
know the way it made me feel very guilty
it made me feel that short of that I had
no reason to to complain or have a
problem and we all do have a reason of
course and we all do have a story
however small and a and I wanted to say
first before we get into anything else
that the measure of a good memoir is not
necessarily although my god
wonderful memoirs have been written by
those people who have suffered
extraordinary pain is not necessarily
having endured indescribable pain the
measure of a good memoir I believe is is
honesty and authenticity about whatever
it is that your experience was I will
add for those of you who have endured
extraordinary pain that this is the
little fringe benefit of having had a
horrible childhood that it does put you
a little ahead of the path
as a writer and and for those four
people in this audience who actually did
have a happy childhood you too also can
overcome that adversity and write a good
memoir as I said I really I decided not
to spend a lot of time talking about my
story because I want to hear from you
but just to give you some idea of what
we might talk about I'm going to give
you an incredibly condensed version of
the story that I tell in my book at home
in the world
a book which I am so sorry to say has
sold out in that bookstore so I know
you're going to go straight to your
amazon.com or better yet your
independent bookseller and get it so I
just want you to kind of trust me that
mine also was a sad story not not a
hopeless story but but I think almost by
definition part of the exploration of
memoir is to explore the painful
discordant parts of our experience and I
find that mine always begins with the
same sentence whatever else changes in
my telling and as I said this is going
to be a very brief one my first sentence
is always I grew up in an alcoholic
family and for those of you who did you
will probably know that there are two
painful aspects of that experience and
only one is the parents drinking and the
other and it's not universally true but
it's usually the case is the keeping of
the secret of your parents drinking and
in my case I would actually name that as
the more painful experience we we had a
daytime life in our family and a
nighttime life I actually and by day my
father was a brilliant funny erudite
extraordinarily dramatic and exciting
artist and teacher a man who had most of
English poetry committed to memory and
recited it at a moment's notice
intimately acquainted with the Bible and
literature and the history of art who
could recreate any of the old masters on
the sand at a gun quit beach when I was
a little girl
then watch the waves wash in and and dub
and wash them all away again by night my
father climbed the stairs to our attic
and drank a great deal of vodka and I
truly believed that we were the only
family in the world who had this problem
because we never talked about it this
was if my parents were both
extraordinarily articulate people people
who loved language above all else that
was really the religion in our household
and our dinner table conversation was
all about art and literature and
politics and philosophy and music and
poetry
there was one subject never mentioned
and that was anything to do with my
father's drinking people from AAA
circles no doubt know the phrase the
elephant in the living room you know and
because of that I felt this was this
terrible shameful secret that I must
never let anybody find out which
established a very early pattern of if
not deception inauthenticity in
communication and in relationships if
you can't talk about the most important
thing in your life you'd better not get
too close to anybody and and and that
was precisely what happened to me
including was my own sister really and
as something that a problem that
probably I'd have to stay indoors to
this day as a result of that no fault of
either of our own so I grew up with the
this enormous discordance II between the
way life really was and the way I wanted
to present it to the world I used to
watch situation comedies on television
like a student I wanted to know what
normal life was these were the the shows
of you know the 1950s and 60s of father
knows best and Leave It to Beaver and
Donna Reed and I actually thought that
that's what everybody else's life was
like and there was something terribly
wrong with me that mine was not like
that another aspect of growing up in an
alcoholic family er I think any troubled
family any family where there is
heartbreak in the parents is this
incredible desire to make their lives
better and in a sense a kind of burden
of responsibility that
the that you are the one to do it in my
case both of my parents were themselves
brilliant and gifted artists totally
sidelined in their own artistic lives my
mother a PhD from Harvard hood as a
woman of the 50s had never been able to
get a job other than tutoring Latin at
$1 an hour and selling encyclopedias
door-to-door my father a very gifted
artist and writer who was who was in a
dead-end job as a junior professor at
the University of New Hampshire for his
entire career and I felt I knew that it
was my job to earn the kind of
recognition and approval that had eluded
my parents I was an obnoxiously
ambitious little girl I can't remember
ever being so young that I didn't start
the day with a to-do list and my to-do
list you know had items like write and
opera paint a mural choreograph a ballet
I was all over the map when I was about
nine years old I wrote a letter to the
president of CBS television to let him
know that if the little girl for those
of you who are 46 years old in this
crowd you might remember the name of the
actress Angela Cartwright if Angela
Cartwright was ever incapacitated in her
playing her role as Danny Thomas's
daughter and make room for daddy I was
available at a moment's notice to
replace her I lived in a small town in
New Hampshire never got the call and so
I my fallback route to success and
recognition and approval and New York
City which is where I always wanted to
get to I didn't know about Key West then
or whatever was writing as I said our
family's religion was language and and
so the way other people played sports we
sat around and wrote and read our work
out loud to our parents who who applied
a more demanding standard than I have
ever encountered in the office of any
New York editor and this was at the age
of eight or nine you know my parents red
pen and yellow legal pad Corrections
so I began sending off my manuscripts to
writing contests and magazines when I
was six or seven or eight began writing
for seventeen
when I was about 14 publishing my work
in 17 and when I went off to college and
college of course had to be the very
best college I could get into and that
was Yale in those days I took a bunch of
my clippings from 17 mailed them off to
the editor-in-chief of the New York
Times with a letter that said it's same
style as the old letter to CBS would you
like me to write for you and I was 17
years old at the time and interestingly
enough he wrote back and said okay and
gay gave me an assignment to write a
piece about what it was like to be a
young person in 1972 by this time I
turned 18 the piece was published in the
New York Times Magazine in April of 1972
I remember the date very well because it
was a date that changed my life
there was an enormous color photograph
of me on the cover of the magazine that
morning and within three days there were
three enormous stacks of mail on the
steps outside my dormitory room and
every kind of offer and opportunity that
I had sought out so assiduously all my
long 18 years were contained in those
sacks letters from editors and
publishers and radio producers and TV
producers I was there was even a movie
director who wanted me to try out for
his film The Exorcist
I obviously did not get the part but it
was a pretty I think it would be a heady
thing even for a 45 year old it was an
extraordinarily heady experience for an
18 year old girl from a small town in
New Hampshire and I might have supposed
that my ship had come in and that the
the rest of my life was now the red
carpet had been rolled before me except
that in among those letters was another
letter of a very different sort and this
was the letter a letter of warning
really a letter telling me a letter
first of all the person who wrote it
seemed to be a to be in possession of
almost magic powers and that was
something I came to believe of him later
because he said you know I bet you've
got sacks of mail outside your dormitory
room filled with letters from book
editors and radio producers and TV
producers and people wanting you to try
out for their movies and I'm thinking my
god
how did he know and I want to tell you
to be careful I really loved that piece
in the New York Times I think you're a
real writer I know something about the
the perils of enormous early success
people will try to exploit you
interesting interesting phrase because
over many years later I came to realize
that probably no person had done that
more successfully than the author of
this letter ultimately people will hurt
you and try to exploit you and I want to
tell you to guard your talent carefully
because I believe that we you and I are
kindred spirits the phrase he used was a
Yiddish phrase that was a very powerful
phrase particularly to a girl who had
felt like such an outsider all her life
Lance it means you come from the same
little shtetl in the old country and he
and I he said were Landsman the letter
was signed JD Salinger well I was
probably less aware of the work of
Salinger than most other students at the
Yale campus that or any other spring I
was a TV watcher not a reader I come
from this highly intellectual household
but I was most conversant with the
episodes of Donna Reed and father knows
best but I did know that that was a
pretty important thing to get a letter
from JD Salinger who even way back in
1972 was a recluse and most of all I
knew that this person was my soul mate I
did not identify him as a romantic
figure in my life I was in a stunningly
naive and inexperienced eighteen year
old girl I had kissed one boy in my life
I recognized this person simply as my
friend my friend and teacher and mentor
and embarked on a correspondence with
Jerry Salinger in the spring of what
came to be my one and only year of
college that April no big surprise and
and almost from the moment that I did
the rest of the world fell away friends
Emily ambitions in New York City I cared
only for the hour of the day and I knew
just when it was when the mail would be
delivered to the Yale post-office and I
would get my letter from Jerry and for
any of you you know who and I'm sure
most of you have read Catcher in the Rye
and know the power of that voice of
Holden Caulfield and the power that that
character has had on now many
generations of young people who believed
that this was the first person who ever
understood them that was the voice that
came to me in but in longhand whispering
in my ear telling me that I was the most
perfect wonderful girl the most talented
the most brilliant the most unique that
he had ever encountered and that he and
I were destined as I said to be soul
mates not surprisingly I felt a need to
go and see him when school got out and
not right away I'd actually been offered
a job that summer at the New York Times
a reader of my first article had offered
me rent-free use of an apartment on
Central Park West
I had a contract to write my first
daughter biography which I was supposed
to deliver very fast before I got to be
too old in those days too old was 19 but
within weeks of meeting Jerry Salinger I
had withdrawn from Yale I had quit my
job at the New York Times left the house
on Central Park West told almost nobody
where I was going and moved in with
Jerry Salinger who was then 53 years old
believing that I would be with him
forever believing with the kind of
inexperienced a belief and trust that
you probably have to be 18 years old or
probably now younger to possess and
questioning absolutely nothing that he
told me absolutely nothing which I would
say is one of the great differences
between being an 18 year old in love and
a 46 year old in love almost from the
moment that I moved in with Jerry
Salinger
the idyllic relationship ended came
crashing down the first day I moved in
and I committed some minor offense he
said you were acting like a teenager and
I don't even mean to joke about it it
was it was an impossible relationship as
if I hadn't shouldn't have known it he
surely should have during the course of
that year I was I was ostensibly writing
my autobiography that was to be
published the next year by Doubleday but
writing it in a very half-hearted way
because Salinger had as you might have
heard absolute contempt for publication
he was manhood of course done
thatalready and left it I had I had
never done it and wanted it and hungered
for it but knew that he disapproved of
it and I was trying wildly to win his
approval so I wrote the book in a very
half-hearted way and and it's it's my
least favorite of the books that I have
written because of that I think it in
the 160 pages of my first crack at a
memoir I never got around to mentioning
that I grew up in an alcoholic family
one of the little details that I didn't
include or that during the period when I
was writing that book I was suffering
from pretty profound eating disorders
and above all never mentioned in this
story that supposedly was written by The
Anointed youth spokesperson of 1972 that
I had dropped out of my Ivy League
college to move in with my 53 now 54
year old lover who happened to be JD
Salinger few little things you won't
find in that book which is now out of
print but quite a collectible I I gather
well three weeks before that book was
due to be published
I saw no connection between these events
at the time but I surely do now on a
vacation to Florida as it happens to
Daytona Beach with Jerry and his two
children who were just a few years
younger than I on a beach in Daytona
Jerry looked at me from our parallel
towels and said I think you better go
home now clear your things out of the
house have everything gone by the time
the children and I get back he put me in
a cab with a couple of $50 bills and
sent me away from his life forever but
if he believed that he could get me out
of his life so easily it was much less
easy for me to get him out of mine I
continue to believe not only in the
months but really in the years that
followed that the man who had expressed
his contempt and disapproval for me was
the wisest purest and best man I'd ever
known and a far more valuable person
than I would ever be although I
continued to work as a writer into
published books and did eventually get
to New York City I felt a kind of
disrespect for what I was doing because
I knew for so long that it fell short of
what salinger's standard for my behavior
would have been and for many years I I
will not describe myself as some kind of
a sad sack who went shuffling through
life I I'm married I raise children I
think I did a pretty good job of it I
supported a family I baked good pies I
ran political campaign but in in in one
way I I continued to feel deep shame and
that was my sense that in the most
significant moment in my life I had
failed I had failed to win the approval
of the person who I had so revered and I
regarded my one remaining obligation as
the obligation of keeping the secret of
Salinger's place in my life and
protecting him at whatever cost to
myself I did over those years write and
publish a great deal of work and I tried
very hard in my writing to tell an
honest story - I was for years writing a
column about family life and although I
was inhabiting a difficult and
ultimately doomed marriage I I felt a
responsibility not to leave some reader
out there feeling the way I used to feel
as a kid watching those perfect
situation comedy families feeling what's
wrong with me so I I tried to tell an
honest story about many aspects of a
woman's life I did ultimately explore my
father's alcoholism
difficulties in the reality of trying to
be a woman raising young children and
and having a career and holding on to a
marriage and and then the the end of my
marriage but always through all of those
years there remained one story that I I
felt I could not tell and my inability
to that to tell that story colored all
the other stories and and my ability to
to make sense of everything that came
afterwards and that was pretty much
where I stood until three years ago when
my own daughter Audrey turned the age
that I was when Salinger first wrote to
me and it was no longer a choice to
explore this story on the story came
back full in my face as unfinished
business tends to do at one point or
another and I for the first time in over
20 years
re-examine the letters from Salinger and
what that episode had meant and embarked
on the writing of this memoir I I can
tell you a whole lot more about that but
I'm not going to I'm going to sort of
wait and hear what you what interests
you to explore I will just say that the
the telling of that story and my book at
home in the world is not confined only
to that story but that story continued
to reverberate through everything else
that happened in my life the writing of
that memoir was a wonderfully liberating
experience people always ask me you know
what was it cathartic to write your book
well yes it was but my catharsis
shouldn't cost you $25 or now 14.95 so
if that's all it was it would have been
best to stay in my in my dresser drawer
I happen to believe that sometimes a a
successful authentic examination of
one's own story can be helpful to a
reader in the examination of his or hers
as well and I hope that's what I did as
wonderful as the writing of this book
was the publication I have to tell you
was hell and I'm not ashamed to tell you
in fact I'm rather proud that when at
home in the world was published a year
ago this last fall the Jonathan Yardley
the critic for the Washington Post
called this the worst book ever
published
I already told you about aging nymphet
kiss-and-tell [ __ ] was another one I was
charged with of course the invasion of
Salinger's privacy and above all with
with being a woman who couldn't keep her
mouth shut
one critic wrote Joyce Maynard isn't fit
to take out JD Salinger's laundry and
interesting an interesting prerequisite
for writing a memoir you better you
better be as good a writer as JD
Salinger before you attempt it and I'd
love to talk about all of those things
but at the core what we're really
talking about is of course a writers
write and not just mine but that of
everybody in this room to explore her
story and to and that means not just to
explore the stories of all the nice
people that we've met and all the happy
times that we've gone through but the
very darkest ones I think I said the
other day but I'm going to say it again
because it is so important I think to
consider that not a one of those critics
ever said I don't believe what she said
it doesn't sound true to me they said
she shouldn't have talked about it and
and that's something whether you read my
book whether you care about my story or
not that concerns everybody in this room
not only everybody who is a writer but
everybody who is a reader whether you
truly want to live in a world where
where a writer does not have permission
to tell the complicated stories the
shocking stories deliver bad news about
some important person and it turns out
and it seems to me directly in
opposition to everything that young
people are told to believe you know to
that to talk about their experiences to
trust to have faith to you know to come
forward and certainly as writers
everything that we're told to believe to
to go to those hard places I don't
actually want to say another thing right
now I want to hear what's what's on your
mind
officially the topic today I believe is
somebody can probably tell me but it has
to do with hurting people's feelings and
I suppose that this book probably did
hurt JD Salinger's feelings actually
more significantly in my mind I had to
consider a lot of other characters in my
life who who got a lot less press in the
reviews of my book and that had to do
with my parents my former husband the
feelings of my children and I'm guessing
that a lot of you who are writing your
own stories are worrying about those
things too so let's talk about it who's
got something to just throw out yes oh
right okay good
I've been working for about a dozen
years and I've published a lot of pieces
most recently I've been writing a little
bit about my family and it's only just
begun to occur to me that my small child
never asked to be written about and yet
she has been and I wondered what your
feelings are on that type of person who
wanders in and out of your life and ends
up getting written about about their
bright figures I bet your small child is
wandering in and out of your life big
time do I have a microphone um we have
so much to say I can't even wait for my
microphone loss I'll stay put here okay
I'll stay put stay put
all right okay get away good I'm all set
you can hear me
no okay you can hear me now
I think this work okay all set
you can hear me good okay well the the
question was such an important one and
it has to do with our children
first thing I'll say very interesting
I've probably spoken and read from and
you know addressed audiences about 200
times since this book has been published
and every there has yet to be a day that
I haven't been asked how do my children
think about this how do my children feel
about this totally valid question if I
were in the audience listening to me I
would ask that question too but I'll add
I have I have yet to meet a male author
who's been asked this question it I have
yet to meet a male author who's been
asked this question and I think the
difference is and I don't fault you for
asking it as I said I'd be doing it to
that that it is a an obligation uniquely
placed on women to to somehow manage to
be good writers as long as we take care
of everybody else first as long as we
don't offend any of our loved ones
that's the job of women we're you know
Norman Mailer can be as shocking and
outrageous or Philip Roth as he wishes
to be but women still have to be good
mothers first I have I have to end
sometimes sometimes the two are in would
appear to be in direct opposition and
the material that will make the best
work will come from the woman who is the
cruelest and most unthinking mother to
publish things that will be so painful
and given the choice probably between
doing the absolute best work and
betraying my children I'll go for being
the better mother that said I have to I
have to say as a woman who did in fact
write about her children for years
I think it's an allusion to suppose that
any of us goes through this world
without constantly bumping into so many
other people having an effect on their
lives and being affected by them and
nobody's going to you know turn around
and sue you or be offended because
somebody coughed on you and you got
their germs but somehow we've got this
idea or at least you know we have we
have this idea about a famous person
like
sure that you know he can write letters
to a teenage girl teenage girls but I'm
he can go out there and intersect with
my life but I must not make reference to
that your daughter of course is in a
completely different category and I
would I would honor her with a lot more
protection I would feel a lot more
obligation to her to respect her privacy
I also feel whatever it is that is our
that is our passion and our work has
some good and bad aspects for our
children and that if you if you are
giving your child love and care and
attention and support then and the model
of a mother who is doing something she
loves with passion that may be more
important than that you occasionally
mentioned that she peed in her diapers
or didn't have diapers on when you peed
on the book I have you know I've written
things about my children that were I'm
sure some embarrassment to them and and
a few times things that I wish I could
take back and increasingly as my
children got older I chose simply not to
write about those topics because there
was no way to write in an honest way
about being the mother of a 12 year old
girl without talking about a daughter
discovering her sexuality and I wasn't
going to go there while I was living
with a twelve-year-old girl I knew that
that and so in my and really that was
the moment that I entered into fiction
and my children's teenage years have
been largely my fiction writing years
for that very reason I did not it was
more important that I have a good
relationship with them then that I then
that I tell every single fascinating
story that I could have told I bet she's
going to forgive you
if you know the other the other measure
is you I don't even have to ask you you
adore your daughter
so whatever complicated things you may
be saying about her finally
your love will come through in my book I
I wrote some very disturbing stories
about my mother as it happens my
mother's dead and and it probably
truthfully would not have been possible
for me to write with as much honesty
about my mother if she had if she had
been alive but really what I knew was
that that any honest rendering of the
character of my mother was going to be
an extraordinarily complex one that my
mother is a respecter of good writing
would would would recognize that herself
actually and that finally when the day
was done she was going to emerge as a
lovable character and as a character
that that the reader could sympathize
with and understand it and and readers
have told me that that's the case when
you write out of bitterness and
vengeance I think it comes through and
that's a lousy thing to do and and not
only lousy as a human being but lousy
for a reader I don't think readers enjoy
that yes I hope you realize that you've
been in the situation of being that
person has blown the whistle the person
who has subjected to blaming the victim
and finally the person subjected to the
idea of shooting the messenger and all
of those are very real phenomena that
occur in a lot of other situations the
person who points out that there's
something wrong with a nuclear power
plant is the only one who gets fired um
thank you I do know that and it's been a
great comfort to know that I it took me
a while for that to sort of sift through
because you know I was still as recently
as the fall of 1998 that girl who at
some core level needed approval and I
wanted very much the approval of the
Washington Post and the critics from the
New York Times and and you know all
these sort of important literary types
to tell me that I'd done a good job
ultimately it's your approval that I
care about and and readers have not
disappointed me I think it's it's been
much more you know this issue of oh my
god she's written about you know this
this sacred
very figure is much more something for a
rather small group of literary pundits
to huff and puff about and not the
readers at large
yo-oh and Germany wrote you that letter
with his life experience and his use the
words as we know from the book knew that
he was that he was using the most
exploitive tool you could ever do and
making an eight-year-old feel totally
perfect and lovable and acceptable do
you think he laid the groundwork for for
being the most exploited it's the worst
the person ultimately must have
exploited you the most and did he ever
acknowledge that to you or anybody else
later you know I took pains in in the
writing of my book and the telling of
this story not just the part of the
story having to do with Salinger but all
parts not to impose judgment or
interpretation on the actions of other
people besides myself it would be I
think presumptuous and I say this I'm
trying wherever possible to expand
beyond the telling of my story to what
might be helpful for other people who
are telling theirs I think it's a reader
of a memoir expects expects a very
distinct point of view which is which is
not a fully objective one from a writer
about her own life but I don't think
it's fair to the reader to to project on
to other characters what's going on in
their head and I didn't do that I really
wanted to give you the reader the
opportunity to draw her own conclusions
about that I can only say that part of
what what unfolds in the telling of my
story is that years after this event was
was behind me and I was married with
three children I began to hear about
other young women from for all of those
years I certainly know knew that
Salinger had no use more use for me but
I had held on to this notion
I had been the one and only Landsman and
first at a cocktail party in New York I
heard about a girl who had letters and
then over the years and much more since
the publication of this book I heard
about more and more and more always
young girls who got letters the list is
in the double digits now of the people
that I've just heard from personally
myself and interestingly I have to say
you know although ultimately what I
think is most significant for us to
discuss is not the injustice has done to
my book but once again not one of the
critics of this book mentioned the
extremely well-documented phenomenon
that a man who you know the whole
literary world has been speculating for
over 30 years now oh my god what
Salinger writing you know holding on to
any little scrap of information you know
when will we find out about the books
they're published for all the world to
see in in a book that came out a year
and a half ago was concrete information
that we know very well at least one
substantial activity that's writing
activity that JD Salinger has been
engaged in for 30 years
and nobody pays it any mine six months
ago in a whole whole PhD dissertations
have been produced on you know the
meaning of the Red Hat and Catcher in
the Rye taking it apart we have so
little that we know about Salinger so
every little crumb will study and here I
publish three hundred and some pages of
pretty concrete information and
dismissed six months ago as some of you
may have heard you know I actually
believed after this book was published
in 1998 I thought well there's nothing
left bad that they can say about me so I
might as well I had three children going
into the heavy duty tuition college
years doesn't mean I'll do anything for
a buck there are a lot of things I won't
but I had absolutely no moral
compunction about doing this I decided
to sell my letters from Salinger at
auction at Sotheby's and when these
letters were put up for auction I really
didn't think as I said that there was
anything more that they could say about
me boy was I wrong and interestingly and
here once again we now had forty some
pages of a writer that
the world has been hungry to hear from
for 30 years and at last we've got these
pages on display you could have gone to
Sotheby's in New York made an
appointment sat down in red JD Salinger
they were always described as love
letters I have to tell you as the woman
most intimately acquainted with these
letters these were not love letters
there were no throbbing body parts
described in this in these letters these
were not mushy gooey embarrassing
letters and and probably if they had
been I would have had to have made a
different choice and and the story would
have been a different story this was 40
some pages of one of the most
significant American literary figures
talking about what books writing the act
of writing the glass family his family
Catcher in the Rye movies his children
New York City in the 40s the war forty
some pages of Salinger at his best on
those subjects occasionally he'd say
some pretty nice things about me too
what happens to these letters believe me
if I if I had been in a financial
position to do so I would have donated
them to a university library where they
truly belonged they were purchased by an
extraordinarily wealthy man who decided
to return them to Salinger so they could
be destroyed sad tale as it happens
there are many more sounds or letters
out there however and I won't say who
has them but I've heard there are some
Xerox copies of these
yes oh I'm sorry I'll get to you next I
guess there's a microphone here for this
person we're women reviewers as critical
of your honesty in telling your stories
as men I'm looking for where the person
is oh okay sorry what you know I hate to
say women were the worst women beautiful
leg women were the worst I think what it
is is that women there's an enormous
amount of self-hatred in women writers
to you know make sure they have
experienced what it can be to be a woman
in the world and they're going to
distance themselves from it and the
worst thing that a woman can write about
is her emotional life her sexual life
you know they say my god she wrote about
this book and she included sex well try
to tell an honest story about a 53 year
old man who writes letters to an 18 year
old girl and not include what happened
sexually between those people sex is a
part of life you know as it happened it
was a very small part of this
relationship or a very disturbing part
of this relationship
but once again male writers if a male
writer goes into the territory of sex
he's macho and brave and if a woman does
it she's a [ __ ] and I'm hardly the first
who's who's had that experience being a
very strong feminist myself I believe
that you have absolutely been abused by
all these critics and I do believe that
as a woman you have been treated
differently there's some little Club of
these men that want to protect Salinger
which you have implied and you also
obviously are extremely angry about this
that comes through in everything you say
especially when you repeat that you were
declared an aging nymphet which would
embrace me if anyone said that but as a
person as an artist and I'm a
photographer I believe in your right to
explore any material that you ever come
across you have the absolute right as
far as I'm concerned to do that
especially in this country which
believes in freedom of expression and if
there are dire circumstances you have
the right to talk about the
explore them we have a right to
criticize the critics but I think that
for example it's your motive I mean you
did not set forth to write this thing to
get back at this man I mean you were
writing a memoir and this was very
important to your life now I've done
some photography in my life of a very
intimate family things for example
funerals family members crying in a deep
grief bedside deathbed scenes things
like that which people were kind of
upset about at the time that I took them
but I believed that I had the right to
do that and those were images that
needed to be made and I did them and I
do not regret them and if they're
they're going to be in an exhibit that's
great and think about the exhibit of the
lynchings that is in New York right that
a good is very powerful exhibit and this
is all about talking about the truth
which is what you're really doing and I
applaud you thank thank you you know I
want to say it's so interesting when you
experienced a surprising initial
response when you said that I was angry
I could feel myself getting really
defensive for a second thinking because
I was so well taught not to my
publishers actually said be sure when
you go out and promote this book don't
ever show that you're angry I was being
a good girl and actually if I if I don't
reap lay my early appearances on Charlie
Rose and Today Show
but if I were to be on those programs
now I would be comply would be angry I
was
so specifically schooled and I don't
just mean schooled by my publishers I
mean schooled for the last 45 years of
life not to be angry and I was even as
recently as you know two minutes ago
when you said that I thought oh my god
I'm betraying that I'm angry I've got to
be nice yes frankly I am angry and
and I'm you know I'm not just angry on
my behalf I will be okay I wasn't sure I
was going to be for a while frankly
because it was a devastating thing what
happened when this book was published
and it was sort of devastating
professionally and it was devastating
financially and lots of things I will be
okay I am I am angry on behalf of my
daughter and our daughters and I'm angry
on behalf of every writer who's going to
want to tell a difficult story which you
know will be okay as long as it's not
about certain people yeah
I don't pretend anymore that I'm not and
it's actually I have to tell you and I
have my friend Judy to thank for this
it's a very unique experience that I'm
even at a literary conference I don't
get invited to literary conferences I
really don't and I'm and and it's fun I
mean I it's okay I have other parties to
go to you know but but I I have not I
have not been acknowledged as a writer I
have been acknowledged as a
kiss-and-tell
woman which basically is saying that the
one significant event of the life of a
46 year old woman who's published seven
books you know raise children done all
the things that so many of us have was
that one time she slept with a famous
man and isn't that a sad story and sad
reflection on our times
oh I'm sorry I guess I keep on calling
on people and I guess there's a rule
here yeah miss Maynard a couple of
questions one is it seems to me that
although the the you wrote a book about
a very significant and interesting
experience that what you're going to
know the publication would also be the
subject of a book too and I would love
to read that book so my first question
is two parts are you considering such a
book and secondly with all the
experience you've had with the feedback
and the anger directed at you based on
having written a memoir as a woman and
broken some new ground what is your
advice to other women memoir is what are
some of the subjects we can expect to
get a lot of negative feedback on and
maybe those should be the subjects we
approach because they need to be
approached wonderful question wonderful
question no I'm not going to write a
book about the response to this book I I
think I have lived with this story quite
long enough and this is actually I'm
happy to say this is my absolute last
appearance having to do with this book
and then I'm going to go home and get
back to the novel that has been very
difficult to to really get into well
this kind of toxic experience has been
hanging over me
I am proud that I wrote the book I
wouldn't change one sentence of it I
hope you read it and I hope you tell
your friends about it and I I will
always be pleased that I've written it
but it's over and one of the best things
that I can say about writing a memoir is
that it frees you to tell all the other
stories that are not memoirs so I'm not
gonna be the endless documenter of my
life I wrote an afterword for the
paperback edition of my book that
addresses the experience of publishing
this book and that's kind of enough as
to the second half of your question
which is so important you know how
should women approach knowing you knows
where what happened to me Google for it
is what I have to say and there will be
a sort of a critical mass go for it and
you know we all had women who came
before us who took the flack that made
the next group take a little less flak
and interestingly enough next fall
Geri Salinger's
daughter Peggy who's now 42 years old is
evidently publishing a memoir and
although I'm done with this experience
I'm not so done that I'm not going to
buy that book and I can tell you I can
tell you that there's no way that that's
going to be a loving reverential
treatment of her father because there is
no book that a Salinger child could
write with the approval and the blessing
of JD Salinger and the fact that she's
writing this book is an astonishing
astonishing fact you know I could talk
to you forever and it's really sad to me
that we have to close but I wanted to I
wanted to close because we didn't we
didn't I know that there are a lot of
people who struggle with this whole
issue of you know how are people going
to feel and and so I wanted to say a
couple of things to you in parting about
the telling of your story and worrying
if you're lucky enough that your parents
are still alive or you're still married
to your husband and you know whatever
and you're worried about how to do it
number one I would say just do it it is
death to a piece of work to to edit
yourself and and cut off parts of your
story while you're in the act of writing
it write it the way you want to write it
it's hard enough to write anyway without
adding what's my grandmother going to
think and after you've written it that's
the moment to figure out and there's no
one right answer for this everybody has
to assess their family situation where
they stand after you've written the book
you wanted to write the book that will
make you feel happy and proud and that
you told the truth which is the absolute
most important thing then decide if you
need to take parts out and put them you
know in the bottom of a drawer for later
or if you need to hold on to this book
for five years or ten years or 20 years
but write it the way you want to write
it it is an indescribable joy to do that
and nobody should be deprived of that
and I want to just close by reading to
you this is I actually put this in the
afterword to my book I maintain a
website which is my way of keeping in
touch with readers something that was an
assáááá
- Jerry Salinger but is so important to
me as a writer to hear back from readers
and know what readers are saying and one
day on my website there's a discussion
forum on the website if you ever sort of
you know want to talk about something
not necessarily me or my work but just
what's on your mind that that website is
a place that people go and discuss
stories in their lives it's Joyce
Maynard calm I was the critic for Time
magazine said imagine her website is
named after her
she's such a narcissist anyway say so um
but I'm not angry really I'm so nice
so a woman came to my website and she
she was huffing and puffing there were a
lot of people who were huffing and
puffing about this book and the
particular thing that she said was oh my
god you know what are your children
someday you'll be sorry you know your
children are going to read this book and
how will you feel then boy well my
children do not hang out at my website a
whole lot they much more interesting
things to do but it happened that my 14
year old son Willie was walking through
the room just as I was reading this
message that this woman had posted and I
was just because he was walking to room
I said Oh Willie listen to this
somebody's writing about you wondering
about how you feel about this and
hearing her comment Willie who I have to
say is a fine Cracker Jack in fact
writer himself said excuse me mom would
you mind if I answered this and he's
that down this was the one and only time
he's ever gone on my website and posted
this is word-for-word what my son Willie
wrote about the subject that I'm sure
many of you were wrestling with and I
have to I I won't even attempt to
conceal from you how proud of my son I
am Oh Kathy I have read my mother I love
that Oh Kathy Oh Kathy I have read my
mother's most recent book and though
parts were hard to hear I was glad to
read every page of it I am sure that in
your own life you too have been faced
with adversity and pain that affected
you profoundly as has my mother the fact
that she chose to express hers in
writing is I believe a sign of her
strength and an expression of the faith
she has in her children raised that boys
allowance
I am the youngest of my siblings and
possibly the least mature however not
for a moment do I suspect any
conflicting feeling from my fellow
siblings when I say that we all love and
support our mother despite her zany
stories of despair and whoa
I think that we can all relate and learn
from these tales if they're approached
with an open mind and in my case a
little love sincerely Steven Wilson
Bethel thank you so much
I can't tell you what a pleasure it's
been to be here to the signing in Allah
because your city on an address on this
page oh oh okay